right nowadays a lot of people are
focused on weight management but the
day-to-day stress is not helping us
right dr lana dawood of intermountain
healthcare the sponsors of this segment
she's here with some answers so much
needed answers because i'm sure coming
out of quarantine and the pandemic and
inflation and all the crazy things
happening around the world
weight gain is excessive right now
what are you seeing out there
so you are right so weight gain is um
is that is the
as a result or a byproduct of unhealthy
lifestyle mainly is
excess calorie and lack of exercise all
of that add together can add to the
weight and of course you're guaranteeing
gyms were closed cooler clothes we
worked from home so that added a lot to
them
definitely and personal stress all the
things um so let's talk about you know
just explaining weight management and
what goes into that process
so um the way as a provider so when the
patient comes with with a provider we
treat the patient as a whole okay so
first the height to weight ratio
is kind of doesn't give us an idea the
bmi we call the basal metabolic rate
right doesn't give us an idea about the
patient gender athletic activity there's
another
way that we measure the
weight
is the waist circumference so the more
weight around the stomach area that also
linked to the
hypertension diabetes increased heart
attack so this so when we see the
patient we treat them as a whole again
we look at their family history their
lifestyle their ethnic background the
their activity level their stress level
um yeah all of that definitely the
family history a lot of things are
hereditary that's really good point um
you know what causes unhealthy weight
gain though
so there's a lot of
around there right but
to maintain a healthy weight you need
good diet
activity and sleep
so all of these three combined together
um give us a healthy weight a healthy
lifestyle okay but what is a healthy
weight
does it depend on what does it depend on
it depends on the person itself okay so
if your weight is 150 but your blood
pressure is high and the cholesterol is
high and you're diabetic that's not
healthy weight-free okay good to know
good to know good to know and what are
some ways you know that you suggest
people go out and lose the weight the
unhealthy weight the unhealthy weight my
advice is really simple keep it as
simple as possible whole food
so stay away from salt
eat
closer to the farm so fresh fruit fresh
vegetable unprocessed food
is the easiest way okay to lose weight
that is great whether you're having
problems or not that's just a great way
to keep a healthy lifestyle correct
thank you doctor okay thank you to
intermountain healthcare for sponsoring
this segment for more all you got to do
is head to intermountainhealthcare.org
nevada